what's going on guys this is rob and i
just want to make this quick video to
let you guys know that a DC explained
youtube.com / DC explained is officially
live I will have a link down in the
description and an annotation on the
screen you guys can check it out and
what we're going to do with DC explained
is I'm starting off with the Justice
League the new 52 and the reason why is
because like the new 52 Justice League
is how we're introduced to the
characters meaning each other for the
first time after that we'll go through
and do their their individual
backstories now the difference here is
that with Superman and Batman we're
going to do the whole chronology going
all the way back to that golden age
running all the way up to the current
age but everybody else we're going to do
the new 52 origins so I just want to
give you guys heads up go ahead check it
out let me know what you guys think and
and yeah so I will catch you guys later
peace